Shawn why is your documentary cam girls
controversial I don't know that it is I
don't know that it is controversial I I
guess I'll see but I think anytime
you're showing women empowering
themselves and especially leveraging
their sexuality to empower themselves I
think that's something that really
threatens people and scares people a
little bit I hope I hope that this movie
goes a long way to lessening that I know
you like subject matter that is maybe
slightly different from the norm or
pushes the envelope a little bit
will you ever make a film that's not
maybe just slightly pushing the envelope
a little bit um yeah probably I mean
that like that's the thing I really
appreciate normal things I thought I
find a lot of inspiration and beauty in
the mundane and average things so you
know that that's that's kind of I'm
always drawn by those things but I do
always end up finding a unique twist on
it or a spin on it that that makes it
feel unexpected so I don't know probably
not probably not to answer your question
well forgive me I haven't seen your
other work but from looking at your IMDB
and just seeing some of the the trailers
and stuff I mean you definitely like
subjects that are very sort of non
mainstream yeah yeah people have said
this one website called me the master of
fringe Americana and I was like oh
that's that's cool that's pretty fitting
description not that I'm always going to
try to live up to that but I think
that's a pretty good description of of
the of the subject matter I've tried to
tackle so far right I mean do you think
you could ever do something where it's
like you know hey corporate dads talk
about their favorite weekend pastime or
yeah maybe but I think I could find an
interesting spin on it that could maybe
say something about the human condition
that that's kind of what I'm what I'm
interested in doing and I do do that
type of work but it's usually paid
that's how we make money well speaking
of maybe possibly their favorite pastime
how did you discover the topic for cam
girls
cam girls you know they were on my radar
a little bit
I remember it really hitting me that I
had to make this film
I was watching just you standard just
watching internet porn with my
girlfriend and one of those you just
hear a voice and you're like where's
that coming from and there's a pop up
sitting there and it's some woman
sitting in some room somewhere speaking
to someone and you're not sure what's
going on and that kind of led me down
this this rabbit hole of of asking
myself all the types of questions that
would lead you to make a documentary
like this so it really it kind of came
from a spark of inspiration where where
I saw this woman and I asked all these
questions about her and I mean my
girlfriend started talking about a
little bit more and then once I heard
them refer to each other as cam girls I
thought that sounds like a title of a
really really rad documentary that I'd
love to see so like let's just make it
let's make it well then how did you
access because you have so many
interesting women all of them are
fascinating they're all such individuals
how did you access them and how did you
get them to even allow you to come to
their home yeah it was tough because I
think that I think what they deal with I
think gaining access to this community
is really tough because they're they're
used to dealing with people like me who
are just fans of theirs who are trying
to gain further access to their worlds
and and Here I am just some dude trying
to gain further access to their world so
of course I think at first we were met
with some resistance but you know what
actually really helped me it was that my
previous film oxy Anna had had really
had some it had a compassionate tone for
people that you wouldn't expect and I
think that they saw that and saw where I
was going with my filmmaking and we were
able to get in with a woman named Sophia
Locke who who runs a thing called the
cam mansion and she just has a whole
bunch of girls get together a couple
times a year and getting a mansion and
cam together so once we got in with her
we were able to meet a lot of girls and
having her introduced us to the
community really helped it really helped
it but you know we had to earn trust
with every single subject there was no
shortcut to this what are some of your
things that you do I mean obviously
showing them your prior work but so that
they know too that you won't cut it in a
certain way because you made all the
girls look great yeah
and you show that there were real humans
but how did you sort of get them to UM I
think part of it this might sound really
hippie dippie it's just being ourselves
and and kind of putting out what you
expect to get back you know I share with
them things about my world I'm myself I
open up I do that on set I do that I'm
you there's one version of me you know
and I think that they start to
understand that and I think I think that
the cam girls really appreciated to that
that there was women behind this project
that that my girlfriend was producing it
and there there wasn't going to be some
creepy thing going on that a woman was
editing it and and that we had every
intention to to celebrate their
lifestyle and to make make the
mainstream kind of questioned their
values instead of questioning the cam
girl's values so kind of holding up a
mirror to the audience I think that they
really appreciated those aspects of
where we were going with this
also the trailer helped we produce the
trailer in order to raise the money and
they saw the tone of that so a lot of
girls were contacting on is based on
that so you do some self disclosure I
know if her therapists say that they do
self disclosure to get patients to open
up so it sounds like in some ways that's
also your way to say it's not even
necessarily to get people to open up
it's just like I'm saying there's like
there's just kind of one version of me
and we're we're not trying to put
anything on there there is no set agenda
so yeah I'm just myself and I'm you know
kind of just like this roving pothead
and I'm pretty harmless so I think
people pick up on that and yeah that's
it I noticed too with the film that you
showed them all Beauty you know all
beautiful and dolled up and in front of
the camera and talking with their
customers but then you had the audio
which was much more sounded like their
real selves and some of the painful
things that they went through how did
you come to that decision to do it like
that well I think it was important to
kind of to show the the disparity the
difference there between what their
on-camera personas are and what their
off-camera personas are and one of the
you know it was it was an immediate
thing where when we first realized we
were gonna make the movie I said to
myself well how am I gonna get through
and get something that's not
what they're used to doing on camera
they're used to being on camera they're
used to
oh I see what's going on you're they're
savvy so to kind of break that down a
little bit what I decided to do was
conduct no on-camera interviews so what
I would do is I would just I would sit
with the girls and wherever in their
house on their couch on their bed I
would get real close to them we'd get a
mic nice and close and we would just
talk for a couple hours and I would call
from from those interviews we put
together the audio that that kind of
underlays over the film and we're
telling two different stories at once
but they really work well together and
you're hearing or something that's
really genuinely them you know I talk
about like it's it's their mid night
voice it's their rated hour voice it's
their just talking to a friend voice and
to be able to get that you know it
wasn't it wouldn't have been guaranteed
if we would have just slapped the camera
in front of them because it because like
I said they're very savvy to that so
instead we we focused on getting through
to their you know down to the nitty
gritty of their stories in a really low
stakes environment I think that that
helps bring out their real voice and is
that something that you just saw over
time because so much when you when you
go to someone's place - they're in on
mode and they want to present the best
PR aspect that they can yeah you just
see it too often when you take out the
camera and someone's like a deer in the
headlights and that that puts the worst
feeling over me as a filmmaker I don't
want to I don't want to make someone
feel like that let alone you capture it
you know for especially for something
like this we're trying to get in there
and and depict what they normally do not
what they're doing like on camera for us
so to make our presence as little-known
as possible is super important to me and
yeah that that's really what fueled that
decision was was that seeing how many
times you try and fail to get somebody
to act like themselves on camera and I
had experimented with this style with
with doing the off-camera interview in
some commercials and I knew it could be
successful in storytelling in us in a
smaller way and my editor and I just
loved the challenge of of doing it for
an entire film for a whole film that
that kind of is interview based but
never really showing an interview I dug
it
that's excellent yeah Shawn with this
technique of getting their audio and
just talking to him one-on-one without
the camera was this something that you
learned from another filmmaker or film I
didn't go to film school I I've had a
lot of influences but not necessarily
specifically for for that style it was
something that like I said I dabbled
around with on commercials a little bit
and realized how it could work and also
just just kind of reading the audience
and seeing what's out there currently
and kind of just kind of going against
the tide a little bit well you know with
with just trying to do something that
maybe is a little bit more engaging and
not what you'd expect so yeah not
necessarily one filmmaker I can point to
in particular but uh lots of guys over
time for sure and women so when you
would go into their homes how many
people were with you Oh
small small four or five people I think
you know at most and when that when the
shows were actually going on when they
were being filmed just our cameraman was
in there and you know because at that
point I had already spoken to them I'd
loosened them up we had done this
podcast style interview and that was
like the pressure was off them and now
they could just be themselves and and
kind of live their life which we showed
some of that and do their cam show
without worrying about us and our camera
guy was the only one in there when when
the shows were going on but besides that
we don't we only had a crew of five or
six people at any given time so when
that camera guy was in there there were
real live customers oh yeah getting show
yeah yeah we didn't contrive anything or
put anything on or do anything for the
camera it was just it was simply you
know we would just tell the girl it's
like it's no pressure we're gonna show
up we're gonna film you're doing what
you normally do and and that's all we
did and you know we were very we were
decisive and bold in our our
decision-making in terms of approaching
the visuals beforehand and I think it
pays off I think it's a very interesting
looking and feeling movie oh absolutely
and I'm wondering when you would go into
each home did you had a specific idea of
what you wanted to film or you'd kind of
just you know you try to you know that
that's where a lot of the decisiveness
comes in
you know me and my producer my
cinematographer sitting down beforehand
and saying what types of situations are
we gonna find ourselves in and how can
we prepare ourselves for those but once
you're there it's like all those things
get burned down and you you're just in
someone's space so you're really just in
the moment trying to notice things
trying to pick up on things and there's
there's a real quick kind of in the
moment conversation that's going on but
a lot of it is just relying on your your
core principle values that you went into
that film for and saying I'm only
existing in this world where we're not
shooting slow-motion we're not shooting
any straight to camera things we're not
shooting any on-camera interviews we're
not shooting any handheld so you know
you kind of you you put a box around
yourself and then try to just be as
creative as you can in there and that
that's all we were doing with this did
anyone try to talk you out of making the
film yeah probably but I ignore
everything anyone says when it comes to
that stuff you know there's a lot of
people out there that uh that troll
documentaries in a way that you know
kind of confounds me you know there
there is a there's a certain like almost
a journalistic expectation that comes
along with it and I don't know I I find
a lot of the people that say you
shouldn't do something I find them to be
boring and they're living their life
through therefore your brain and that's
just not how I live mine what were some
of the the things thrown at you if you
can recall any of them no one to respond
to criticism I just could these things
speak for themselves you know my goal is
to get to the final product and put it
out there and and hope that the that the
conversation becomes really multifaceted
and and that it's starting a discussion
you know that's my hope so
and you know any criticism that happens
at the beginning like oh why are you
doing this why are you making that that
usually is more of an indication about
the fears and insecurities of whoever
saying it and I'm like super aware of
that so I I just it's so easy to ignore
sure sure it's easier and easier to you
know I think a lot of YouTube comments
or the yeah
speaking of sort of the the traditional
route with the festival route I know
with your other film
Oxana that you premiered at Tribeca
wasn't but then you decided you weren't
going to go to any more festivals yeah
and then with cam girls you premiered it
an adult Condor something oh yeah we
just did it we did a screening at at the
AVN Awards and in Las Vegas kind of just
to to dip our toe in the water and show
that industry hey here's something we
made about the adult industry that
industry is huge it's way bigger than
the indie film community and I yeah this
I'm not making films for festivals I
don't know if I'll ever have a film in a
festival again it's just not something
I'm that interested in I think festivals
are something that used to keep us
relevant and now we're kind of there to
keep them relevant and I don't want to
be part of some elitist hierarchy or
anything like that and it's also you
know when you're when you're doing film
festivals and you're and you're saying
okay this is gonna be our path and it's
going to be the festival route there's a
certain complacency and laziness that
comes over you like I got my festival
laurels I'm gonna be fine now
everything's gonna happen for me
but we're not looking for distribution
where we are the distributor's so what
are we going there and doing necessarily
you know so the way I saw it is the fest
of Tribeca was hugely helpful in getting
the word out about oxy Anna and helping
even get in getting this film made but I
need a I need a way better argument than
the current one about why I should be
spending a year on a festival circuit
when I could be out making another film
well I think with oxy Anna you
determined that a lot of your audience
was online yeah I think the whole
audience is online you know for all
these things I'm we're know we're
realistic these films are never going to
be in theaters they're they're not going
to be a big theatrical draw they're
there for niche audiences and therefore
therefore they're made for online
audiences you know but and even so much
so that like we're abandoning the idea
of the feature film and we're just
making our films whatever length they
kind of need to be you know I feel like
that's more conducive to the types of
that are watching I mean the types of
people that I want to watch them you
know vying for the attention of the
indie film community it's gonna send me
down a path where I'm gonna end up not
being really true to myself and honest
with myself so we're gonna we're gonna
bypass that whole thing well that being
said then what fuels you to make these
fascinating movies you don't want to do
the festival round you don't want them
in in you don't want the name on the
marquee or it's not that you don't but
all that goes with that is very costly I
understand them so then what is it that
fuels you because there's a lot I'm sure
that goes into making these films oh
they do you know it's it really to me
it's about it's about the process and
it's about living in the process and
that's the same thing for the five or
six people that end up working on these
things it really is about living the
process and getting in there and what
we're trying to accomplish with any of
the films is it's promoting people
expanding their consciousness a little
bit you want you watch this and you see
these people and you accept them for who
they are and you understand what they're
doing better and this isn't just for can
girls as for all the stuff I'm trying to
make and if that can influence you to be
a better person or look at people
different or or look at you know your
niece who's a cam grow without the
judgmental eyes as much you know all
these things can really together when
you kind of look at them as this as this
beautiful mosaic they can they can
increase and and expand your
consciousness and if there's any goal
it's just that acceptance and
understanding what part of that process
I'm sure there's you know because
there's so many steps that initial idea
reaching out to that one contact that's
yeah when you get to access what's the
most exciting for you and then what's
the toughest part um wow that's an
interesting question uh you know you
know what's really exciting is right
before we put them out because you know
how good it is and you know you kind of
have a sense that that people are going
to respond to it and you've gone through
it all and that's that's really exciting
but because because once once it's
actually released it's not yours anymore
it's kind of everyone's to project on it
whatever they want I love that so I'm
really excited those those few moments
with your baby you know alone with your
child I really get excited by that but
you know I feel like the most
frustrating part is when is when you
have the movie and your
head and you haven't done anything yet
you haven't found a subject you haven't
found a title you know or you do have a
title and you have ideas of how it
should look and how it should feel and
what the tone is but you know the
process hasn't even begun that can be a
really anxiety ridden process for a
documentarian because you kind of get
this sense that like the world is
passing you by there's things going on
and we're not out there capturing it so
it's like this super like oh and this
and especially you know with with people
out there like like a vice who-who turn
these things out with such persistence
and you know they're they're kind of
terrible like it makes it tough because
I think like I'm taking on something
called cam girls and it's gonna take me
a year and a half to really sink my
teeth into this and do it properly and
do it justice and get it out there
vice could do this in a week and a half
and and it kind of that can be
frustrating and that that it all happens
in that part of the process where you're
really vulnerable where you're really
vulnerable because it's just an idea and
you're the only one that really
understands it so that that's the part
of the process that I'm learning to
enjoy more and getting more in the
moment of but it's the most frustrating
part for sure real quickly I want to
just talk about the cam girls in the
film some of whom were in committed
relationships had families how how did
that all work in terms of you're coming
in with the camera and you know it was
it sensitive at some point um yeah it
was it was sensitive for a couple of the
girls who didn't want to say I have a
boyfriend because it might hurt them
financially but for the most part the
vast majority of them were if they were
inviting us into their life and if we
were gonna take them the time and money
to go film with them it was like it's
kind of gotta be all or nothing so you
know we would show up and if there was a
boyfriend or something around I would
say dude this is your life man let me
look can we film you yet you know and we
weren't really met with any resistance
when it came to that I think those are
the people that understand and support
these women more than anyone
is their significant others a lot of
them are are intricately involved in the
business but behind the scenes so to be
able to get them in there and show their
normal relationships and that side of
their family life I think it starts a
process of normalizing this which is
kind of the goal you know is to
normalize this and open up a discussion
about sex and sex work that you know
that kind of maybe updates all of our
values and lastly the film being
received in the adult film world versus
indie filmmaking world mm-hmm
which has been sort of more interested
in the film it seems like the adult
video world oh yeah absolutely you know
the the adult industry has and is
beginning to embrace this you know I
don't I don't think that they expected
this to be good at all but our screening
in Vegas went really well and we made a
lot of really good connections there and
who knows what'll come of any of that
stuff but it's been really really
humbling to just see them rally around
it and you know it's really told me a
lot about that industry and yeah they
rallied around me much more than anyone
in the indie film community ever did you
know they're you know that those those
I've had some great I've had some great
experiences in the indie film world and
I've also had some that would that would
discourage most people from even
continuing to do this so that's not
happening in the adult industry they're
used to dealing with adversity and yeah
that they were just so supportive so
supportive